have you ever had a conversation like
this one publicly no I think it'll be
fun all Sprouse from Disney Channels The
Sweet Life is acting Cody Riverdale Big
Daddy friends you're my hero thank you
sweet pea were you pushed into acting I
would hardly call it pushing because I
was eight months old single mom two twin
boys put food on the table so the choice
never really existed you guys are big
stars now yeah
my mother was living vicariously through
the success of her children a person
that grapples with mental illness drug
abuse but primarily narcissism
a wicked narcissism
but that selfishness is something that
the legal system also observed and said
that she was unfit the court had to step
in
your relationship with acting and the
entertainment industry it's been a
journey I loved being on stage I didn't
like the that came with it this
industry encourages the worst qualities
of you selfishness greed you know
authenticity and vulnerability are not
really encouraged trades how do you feel
about that you're given these lessons in
your life so that you can triumph over
them and use the traits that you've
acquired from those lessons over time to
carve out who you are I've got two
pictures here then what are the words
unsaid to this individual
[Music]
I'd probably kick his ass
before we get into this episode just
wanted to say thank you first and
foremost for being part of this
community
um the team here at the diver Co is now
almost 30 people and that's literally
because you watch and you subscribe and
you um leave comments and you like the
videos that this Show's been able to
grow and it's the greatest honor of my
life to sit here with these incredible
people and just selfishly ask them
questions that I'm pondering over or
worrying about in my life but this is
just the beginning for the day of this
year we've got big big plans to scale
this show and to every corner of the
world and to to diversify Our Guest
selection and that's enabled by you by a
simple thing that you guys do which is
to watch so if there's one thing you
could do to help this show and to help
us continue to do what we do it's just
to hit the Subscribe button if you like
this show if you like what we do here if
you watch these episodes please just hit
that subscribe button means the world
let's get on with it
[Music]
code yes okay much of what I do here is
I'm especially at the start of these
conversations is I'm trying to
understand somebody you know I get to
see the Finish Line I get to see their
achievements the behaviors their
personality during my research and I'm
always trying you know this is
ultimately why this podcast came to be
on one hand in the name you hear the
Diary of a CEO and it was really me
trying to show that there's this other
side of these people including myself
there's this other side that we don't
often talk about and on the other hand
just from a very personal perspective
I've come to learn I'm so interested in
like human beings why they do what they
do and what causes them to do what they
do at the very core of it
um what do I need to know about you when
if we Zoom back to your earliest years
to understand the most influential
things moments influences that caused
you to be the complex inspiring
individual you are today hmm
I mean I'm really glad I'm doing this
podcast with you at this time in my life
because for the last year and a half
I've really been thinking about
questions like this what what is it that
that still compels me uh into certain
professional Pursuits or artistic
Pursuits now
um I think when I was younger it was uh
it was definitely a financial pressure
there were kind of two kinds of kids uh
working kids really there was the kids
that were doing it to put food on the
table for Mommy and Daddy and then like
the thespian children you know like like
Mommy I want to go into acting and they
would show up and it would be this huge
gap between philosophies
um between like yeah man it's a job and
like no this is a this is a craft this
is you know this is an art
uh and those kids kind of showed up
around 14 and for me I think
I had trained to kind of workaholism
since I was a child uh in order to one
feel valued by my environment
uh both immediate family and audience in
very many cases that has stuck with me a
work ethic that has stuck with me now to
this day like I I do not feel good when
I am not working and I think a lot of
people can say that uh and that's
something I've been trying to unpack
over the over the last year and a half
is what would happen if I just simply
stepped away for good and enjoyed my
life which is really the purpose of why
we're all here
um would I be content with sitting down
and fishing and growing my own
vegetables and you know living
sustainably or would I get so
disenfranchised and bored that I would
have to take back to the Arts in some
way or another and I think I think the
pressure of my upbringing really
compelled me to continue doing what I am
today I cannot live without the Arts I
mean I I cannot live without performance
or expression in some kind because it's
truly all I know and have known since I
was eight months old
since you were eight months old yeah you
hold the record for being
the guest on this show that started
working the earliest tell me tell me
Well to be fair I don't know if we can
call it work I don't I don't believe I
cued into Consciousness until about like
10 years ago
um when you're a baby you have that kind
of lantern Consciousness where only you
know whatever exists is only in your
immediate purview and then as you age
you know when you start to become less
present you're like wow I'm an adult and
I feel like all the time
um
so I don't know about if I I perceived
it as work but it certainly infused
within me a kind of work ethic as I have
aged
um but yeah it established a
relationship with work
it did
I mean it started for me financially uh
single mom two twin boys put food on the
table she is still able to be a mother
while we can still pursue a sort of uh
Improvement of our lifestyle and and
very many ways she was living
vicariously through the success of her
children but I think uh it's certainly
developed a relationship to
uh professionalism much earlier than
almost anyone else I know
will you will you use the word pushed
earlier were you pushed into acting in
your view well I didn't you know I would
hardly call it pushing because I was
eight months old I don't even think I
would I knew you know I was on screen I
don't remember much of like the early
early the diaper commercials and things
like that so the choice never really
existed
I was there
that's it how do you feel about that
I think gratefulness and ungratefulness
can exist simultaneously and I I am
tremendously grateful of the financial
stability I have acquired now as a 30
year old and being able to say yeah I'm
okay now
um
I think in many ways I traded sort of
the lantern consciousness of Youth and
sort of the Carefree presentedness of
Youth for financial stability that I
would come to appreciate as an older man
but
um
I don't regret too much
I don't I I think if I were to sit here
and talk about regretting my my
childhood within the industry I think
that would be silly it toughened the
hell out of both my brother and I and
many kids that go through that same
thing
um but I'm grateful I'm grateful for the
financial stability of it yeah and I
also am grateful to have done it in a
time where you could get your Gladwell
10 000 hours in anonymously you know if
you did a crappy direct DVD movie Just
for kicks I'm looking at you for anyone
who knows this uh if you did your crappy
soccer movie
it would go to the back of Blockbuster
and no one would see it now with social
media I mean
there's no way that you can
that you can cut your teeth in silence
anymore everyone sees your portfolio
globally and you're expected to put it
on display I find it you know I I feel
quite afraid for young actors now who
have to hone their craft over time but
do it to a global audience that sucks
you've got a you've got a twin brother
yes um 15 minutes older than you yes as
he always likes to yes help people in my
face
your parents you mentioned single mother
I am as I read through your story I saw
a ton of similarities between the way
you described your relationship with
your with your mother and the way that I
often describe the relationship still to
this day with my mother can you tell me
about both your your mother and your
father and the journey you kind of went
on I know at five years old roughly they
divorced sure I I don't remember the
exact timeline of divorce
um but I remember only having one memory
of them being together uh when I was
very very young and then from that point
on my father was in Switzerland and my
mother was in LA he would eventually
move out to LA in order to try and
repair the family
uh but my mother was
um still is uh the kind of tortured
artist type she struggled with uh in
very many ways her place in the world
she she
I think she found a tremendous amount of
self-identity through motherhood and
tried to turn it into a profitable
business at the same time which for
identical twin boys going into acting is
sort of economic loophole through labor
laws that can be incredibly profitable
um so that's what she did and as I've
thought about it it seemed like to me it
made a lot of financial sense to her to
put us into acting it made I think it's
satisfied some sort of narcissism that
she probably had in order to be
recognized as this sort of artistic
success
uh she was a wonderful painter so she
always wanted sort of artistic
legitimacy and validation
But as time went on
uh
I think the entertainment industry just
kind of broke her you know this this
this industry in very many ways
it
encourages the worst qualities of you
as a person
um
narcissism
selfishness
greed a lot of these things that we have
come to know is practically cardinal
sins
um it's one of those things that uh
encouraged a kind of selfishness that
was
uh directly opposed to the very
fundamental idea of motherhood
and As I Grew Older in my case the court
had to step in and Rend my brother and I
towards our father who's an incredible
guy
um but that selfishness is something
that the legal system also observed and
uh said that she was unfit
and I think as I've aged and I've looked
back on a lot of the circumstances of
that entire environment I see a person
that grapples with
mental illness drug abuse
but primarily narcissism
a wicked narcissism the inability to to
perceive anything outside your own
perspective would probably be the
biggest sickness I see
and uh
that just doesn't work with me and the
mother that just doesn't work with being
in a family in general
you know when
when it rains it rains on everyone's
roofs
that's how it goes it takes a village
man
and selfishness
that is encouraged very much like I said
from the industry just doesn't really
work
it doesn't really work for being a
mother
it's easy to look at this that situation
objectively and go okay just don't speak
to them but this is your mother yeah
that's something I've dealt with a lot
too
that's my question which is like how do
you how have you tried to separate the
two there's so many people listening to
this right now who have a member of
their family that is a toxic influence
in whatever way and they struggle with
this idea that it's a big one yeah right
like because they're blood I have to
persist with the relationship I have to
tolerate it whereas if this was someone
who was I just met on the street or in
school I would I would I would
chop up later straight away right
have you dealt with with the duality of
both it being blood but also being
unacceptable Behavior yeah it's a great
question
um
I don't think you ever fully reconcile
it I think it's the difference between
this like kind of immortal abstract
connection to someone this thing that we
call love this this energy not to sound
to California you know but this this
this sort of a mortal connection between
a mother and a child or a father and a
son or or whatever it is
um
and how do you distinguish that
uh from anyone else who you would
immediately cut off
and I think for me I I've recently you
know
I've recently arrived at the philosophy
that almost everything is is some sort
of lesson that we must take and I think
lessons like this when it comes to
parents when it comes to people who are
supposed to be these sort of
um
Immortal almost god-like figures in in
your life especially during your youth
like
that is the greatest lesson for your
Humanity that you can acquire you know
the distinction between love and care
and abandonment and pain as you grow uh
I really
I wouldn't call myself a religious man
but I I do believe that everyone is put
here in your life to have these
interactions with you for some kind of
reason and I know that sounds like
fadedness which can be you know we'll
leave that for another podcast but
um
I think it's uh
I think it's a lesson that you have to
learn and it's all in a way reflecting
back and carving you into the person
that you're supposed to be I also think
it tests your patience and your love
and the people that really persist and
continuously try and find the love after
all the pain consistently we arrive to
the the care and the connection and the
love
even though you've been you know
deeply wounded by the ones who are
supposed to be at your Round Table those
are the strongest individuals in my
opinion
you know if you can if you can
consistently on the other come to the
other side of that conversation and go
I will still choose to care I will still
choose to love
um
that speaks a lot about you
at some point you have to put your love
for yourself of course fast it's the old
oxygen mask analogy your journey with
with your mother you're very young you
don't really know what's going on sure
you're acting you're doing these things
at some point in your adolescence or
Beyond you figure out that this is not
normal behavior this is not acceptable
behavior for a mother and a son sure
when was that
I mean
I guess when Social Services came
knocking it's usually when it happens
um I don't know I would go over to my
father's house because the court gave
primary custody to my mother and this is
one I don't know too much about the UK
legal system in this regard but the
United States legal system is incredibly
biased towards uh towards the mother in
cases of divorce and custody and in this
case it certainly should have been my
father taking custody
um and this is obviously a case-by-case
basis but
um I would go into you know we'd we'd
spend some time with my father like once
a week and we wouldn't be able to eat
candy and do whatever the we wanted
he would you know make us go and
exercise and play outside and
there was a regiment
there was a healthy regimen it wasn't
you know we weren't a lot we we weren't
allowed to do whatever the we
wanted and I think at that point I was
going at when you're a child you go man
this is no fun but as you as you sort of
pan out for a moment and you go wow I'm
actually feeling a lot better here I'm
present here I'm I'm happy here even
though I don't get to eat ice cream all
the time you know so am I making sense
with this please um Social Services
don't get called for eating ice cream no
no they don't and I won't go too much
into that because I don't want to make
this whole podcast about another young
man in LA with mommy issues yeah uh but
I do think that that
the circumstances of my life are are at
least my childhood are much like the
sort of cliche narrative that you hear a
lot about child stars but
um I don't talk about it too much
because I don't ever want to be
perceived as a victim of it I am not and
have never been and never will be a
victim of any circumstance that I am in
I don't wear victimhood on my shoulder I
don't like to act like I am my wounds
and to repeatedly be reminded of my
wounds
um
what happened in my youth happened and
carved me and forged me into the person
I am today for better and for us right
for better for purely better even
through pain
we trade trauma for wisdom that's what
we do as humans when we go through heavy
experiences it deepens our eyes you know
I I I think for me
the reason I haven't really talked about
it too much in the past is because one
the media has a way of sensationalizing
scars and victimhood like this is a
person's character and in very many ways
it is but they don't talk about
the strength that is the byproduct of
pain they talk about the pain which is
useless like it it all it does is
perpetuate the past which I think is is
or a pain that existed in the past
rather than going my god look how well
he's done for himself even though he's
had such a tough tough upbringing you
know I think Oprah is another wonderful
example of this where her story her
origin tale so to speak is is very well
known
um and look at what a beautiful example
of success that she's become over time
you know that to me is the most
beautiful way that I think media can
sensationalize a story of pain but I
find that it's oftentimes not and I also
feel like we're in a climate right now
that
really encourages people to talk about
the victimization of pain more than they
do about the triumph over it the
strength that comes as a byproduct of
that pain and so that's mainly why I
don't talk about it too much because I
don't want to be that guy you know I
don't want to be that guy that's like
are we all the time no man you you're
given these lessons in your life so that
you can
triumph over them and use use the traits
that you've acquired from those lessons
over time to to carve out who you are
one of the things I've mulled over from
speaking to people on this podcast is
about this idea that that that trauma
you describe if it ever goes away you
know should it ask yourself that it's a
good question
it probably I have to say it probably
shouldn't because as you I said earlier
on it's a lesson that you learned so
that you could deal with your
environmental circumstance and just like
the lesson I learned of not putting my
hand into fire I'm not going to unlearn
that at 30. no there's no therapy that
could that could help me worse and
unfortunately I'm speaking for myself
here I don't know about you but I'm a
dumbass that needs to learn by his own
mistakes I mean I can watch my father go
hey man yeah you need to drink water at
this Watering Hole but I you know you
can't drag me there and make me drink I
have to make mistakes in order to learn
from my mistakes and a lot of my friends
are very similar but um
I don't think I don't think those
lessons should ever go away like I said
about my my validation thing sticking
sticking around with me sure what stuck
around with you
um the workaholism is definitely stuck
with me uh I need validation a lot
I think that's a pretty common
uh uh thing for most artists just to
have
um but I am
the byproduct of the byproduct of
um moments of incredible narcissism and
moments of severe self-loathing and
right in the middle is when I do my best
work
um but a lot of that
operation and the fluctuation between
those two things uh is determined by
people going goddamn you're good what if
they say what if they invalidate what if
they say God damn you suck I spiral of
course but I don't let it hang on me I
try not to let it hang on me what does a
spiral look like
um man maybe I should just run away and
and not do this and you know get some
chickens and raise you know get some
eggs and live off the grid and and
whatever it is
um
it also manifestes the inability to sort
of say
your desires out loud for fear of of
looking like a fool
um I think
La does that too because I think
vulnerability is just something that we
don't really encourage here in Los
Angeles why is that
um because it's not cool
but it's not cool
uh
uh to angelino's because someone that is
cool hasn't said it like that before do
you know what I'm saying it's a lot of
imposter syndrome in Los Angeles and so
you know authenticity and vulnerability
are not really encouraged trades
um before you arrived I was saying to my
team
I was like I watch all these interviews
with people like yourself from La that's
a Stars actors and I go no one's ever
asked them an interesting question it
seems but genuinely that's how before
you walked in this is what I was saying
because Lucy Hale was the same she goes
oh this is the first time I've had a
deep conversation and I'm like why and
then I mimicked what interviewers are
like he was like hey uh where did you
get your shoes yeah
yeah
yeah of course who the wants to
talk about that does people actually you
know yeah yeah yeah I mean because it's
safe yeah right because it's a safe
thing you know this is why I love the
podcast space is because the podcast
space creates new ones yeah nuance and
and context a viewed it gives you the
whole context right there which is
something that a lot of people you know
in interview settings or otherwise are
completely devoid of when you're selling
a publication when you're selling an
interview with someone on paper you
don't really get the context oh well the
context was it was pouring rain outside
for the last blah blah blah and you
arrive to the studio and you got to sit
down and have a tad and we talked about
having similar birthdays and we talked
about Botswana beforehand blah blah blah
blah blah you know you get the context
you get the connection which I think is
gorgeous
and I think it also creates a really
beautiful way to discover the honest
humanity and opinion of people
because
we're you know entertainment media it's
Sensational we're only going to sell the
worst person in the world and the best
person in the world we're not going to
sell the humans in between
you know and and most of us fit as soon
as a kind of gray morality that doesn't
really you know we're not not all of us
are these outliers that are like
these really firm radical people
that are that are saying these
radicalized things in order to preach to
the to the sensationalism of the
internet most of us have these kind of
moderate places that we sit
um so I think the podcast space is
awesome for that man you really
get to to sit and connect to people and
have a conversation and for people that
are interested they listen it's
great a quick word from one of our
sponsors I've got a tip for all of you
that will make your virtual meeting
experiences I think 10 times better as
some of you may know by now Blue Jeans
by Verizon offers seamless high quality
video conferencing but the reason why I
use blue jeans versus other video
conferencing tools is because of
immersion their tools make you feel more
connected to the employees or customers
you're trying to engage with and now
they're launching one of their biggest
feature enhancements to impact virtual
events so far called Blue Jean Studio I
actually used it the other day I did a
virtual event using the studio which I
think about 700 of you came to TV level
production quality all done by one
person with very little technical
experience on a laptop so if you've got
an event coming up and you're thinking
about doing it virtually check out blue
jean studio now let me know what you
think because I genuinely believe I know
this is an advert and I'm supposed to
say this but I genuinely believe it's
the best tool I've seen for doing really
immersive simple but high quality
production virtual events your journey
with your relationship with
acting sure and the entertainment
industry yeah it's been a journey oh for
sure man
can you give me kind of like a timeline
of that journey and how you've felt
through the process with your
relationship with acting absolutely
um
started at eight months old
when you say that it still baffles my
mind diaper commercials things like that
dick commercials
um
worked on a sitcom for a bit
uh still wasn't really fully conscious
uh we were still doing the baby acting
thing I did a sitcom called Grace Under
Fire a couple other little TV spots here
and there identical twins switching
places blah blah blah then we booked big
daddy with Adam Sandler when we were
around six
um and that was like the big thing at
the time this point about the use of
twins in acting yeah some people might
not understand the context oh okay you'd
like me to explain yeah children can
only work a certain amount of hours
which is a very strange thing to say out
loud
um in the button factory in the coal
mines we can only work for two hours a
day uh no but we can only work for a
certain amount of hours
um and so if you have two twins that
look identical to each other that people
can't perceive as anything other than
the same character you double the amount
of hours you can work
which is an incredible economic loophole
for a lot of young actors because to
clean the jackpot yeah yeah of course of
course it was great
work the system baby but the problem is
when you start
at least from that philosophy and you go
into an art you know
um we've commodified almost all of the
Arts that exist but when you enter into
a form of expression in a
professionalized or or work Dynamic it's
hard to see that as a pursuit of passion
so my journey through acting over time
has been one of trying to balance art
and Commerce in a way one for the money
too for the show sort of thing where
I need to be reminded consistently to
myself that I love this thing do you
know what I'm saying
making my money becoming financially
stable getting financially stable taking
jobs that are uh
that aren't paying as much but doing
cool projects and making yourself feel
more in love with the discipline
and I think you know
this is this is a particular approach
that has to come from a certain
socioeconomic background if you are
you know this nepo baby conversation has
been huge out here in La I don't know
how how big it's been out in the UK but
um if you come from a financially stable
background and you can see it with any
actor that has a really Stellar resume
where you're like God you've picked
great movie after great movie after
great movie you've been a part of all
these really cool projects well they
probably had a lot of financial
stability because those projects pay you
nothing
right so if you have the sort of Patron
that is allowing your freedom of
expression to take these artistic
projects and reinvigorate this passion
for you even in the face of
commodification of an expression then
you can uh you can have a really Stellar
career but if you also have to make
money alongside it you're probably not
going to take the super cool jobs you
gotta you know you gotta sell drinkable
yogurt uh for a little bit in order to
go to college you know what I mean yeah
yeah this is the balance between art and
commerce that a lot of people don't
understand in almost every other art at
least in photography this is a great
example no one looks at
someone doing a commercial gig and then
going back to the editorial world and
going why would they do that commercial
again yeah it's a little strange but in
acting they do there's a huge division
between those two people massive
Big Daddy yeah that's where we left off
wasn't it yes big daddy so got Big Daddy
it's six
um Adam was just incredible we shot that
movie for far longer than it needed to
be shot in New York City
um it's my first time going to New York
uh and then that was a whirlwind
were you cognizant at this point of your
feelings with acting that your
relationship with the industry no it was
super present okay which is good which
is what I think we're all trying to get
back to is this sort of lantern
consciousness of of Youth in terms of
acting this is a state of play because
no one should go into acting and be like
I'm going to act
no that's
I don't think that's yeah I don't think
that's right
um but I was still very present at the
time
and then big daddy came out and
alongside it came this Whirlwind of
opinion and conversation and fame and
and all this sort of stuff
which would then which was very
polarizing but would lead me into I
worked on
um a couple other direct DVD movies at
the time for some cash money
and then uh
did friends I was a recurring role on
friends and then
uh Dylan and I would end up booking
uh The Suite Life on Disney which of
course was another huge lifesaver
um and your relationship with acting at
this point is what you're very
commercial okay are you enjoying it
um not really because now it had become
a thing that was taking me away from
playing in the cul-de-sac with the
friends you know what I mean so
I loved school like I loved going to
school I loved playing with my friends
and and all that sort of thing so at the
time I couldn't see it as anything other
than that but that's you know that's
what a child does
um
and then we did The Sweet Life and then
I actually really did not mind not going
to school so we were homeschooled from
The Suite Life lawnmowers and then every
every conversation because I kept a lot
of my super close friends you're 12 and
15 at this point uh this would yeah so
we did that from 12 to 18. 12 to 18. oh
in the Sweet Sweet Life yes would be The
Suite Life on Deck to spin off
um and when we got to high school age
all of my friends would tell me these
stories from high school American public
high school that was just like God damn
you lived through that I don't want
to be part of that at all this sounds
horrible and so then I was quite
thankful to not be doing that
um and then I went to college
you picked up photography around this
time I did around 18. I actually went to
London and the first time I went to
London I said I should give myself a
camera and document my brother a nice
little journey through London I found a
really curious quote that you said about
the reason why you chose photography
sure
um relating to it allowed you to escape
your depression yeah yeah I think a lot
of people um
have sort of
discussed that one quote
um I I think I was certainly
I had gone through a huge breakup after
college
right at the end of college
um and re and picked my camera up again
um and you put a lot of my emotional
state into just shooting hobbyism which
is a real wonderful uh thing to do when
you were feeling sad is pick up a hobby
dive into hobbyism
um
and so I pushed myself into a lot of
that
uh and in very many ways it allowed time
to pass more quickly and for me to heal
more effectively yeah
but I also did it because I wanted to
express my vision
in very many ways when you're an actor
you are the byproduct of the writing the
direction and the editing and a lot of
people assume you have much more
creative agency over a project than you
do but I don't find that to be the case
when you're a commercial employee actor
you know when when you were working on
Commercial projects in very many ways
there's they're controlling the image of
you that people are seeing
um and they control the takes and you're
as bound to the project uh as the
writing is good or bad and the directors
are changing week to week so it's a
difficult relationship to expression
and self-identity and I I think at the
time I was really looking for a way to
tell people hey
this is what I can do if I'm given
creative freedom
um I don't think I've achieved that
no your work is amazing as I was saying
she wasn't just blowing smoke up your
ass I I went on your website I thought
oh we're moving into a new house me my
girlfriend I thought this would be
brilliant if we come out I'll just send
you something
yeah I hate I hate anything I I do after
two weeks so I'll send you some of the
newer stuff textbook creative yeah
when's the moment in your life where you
both loved and then the moment where you
hated acting the most I came back to it
yeah you know I used College yeah I was
at real fork in the road and I um
made a promise to someone that I would
return to acting but I never anticipated
I would and I was reminded that I love
performance
which is I love to perform in front of
people
um and I love the presentedness of a
performance like when you wake up at the
end of the take and you go man I don't I
barely remember what I was even doing
right there that was I just felt that
um I love that I love performing for the
crew I love
I loved being on stage I didn't like the
that came with it
because when I was young
you know acting was like the grilled
chicken of the dish it was like it was
the biggest part of the course and the
side salad was like the red carpet stuff
and and whatever the it is and now
that social media has made it so that
the whole thing's just a grilled chicken
salad now I mean like like the salad is
almost a bigger part of your success
than the act the act of performance and
I think in very many ways
you know your celebrity profile has been
become far too intermingled into your
work as a professional and all of us
within the industry are recoiling and
trying to figure out a way to to
you know figure out how to deal with
that
I I was I have to be honest I had a good
laugh at your other Instagram account
camera duels yeah that's polarized a lot
of people but but I at the same time I
thought I underst
I read about your sort of social anxiety
that came with came along with the fame
and then I heard you'd created this
Instagram account of taking people
taking pictures of people taking
pictures of you covertly without asking
permission and then I thought to myself
this is a great idea but it's going to
encourage it yeah of course it did yeah
I know it totally did which I I don't
mind as much
that it encourages people
um
because all it's done is just further
reinforce why I've done it yeah which is
like hey people are not going to care
about anything other than the uh then
bragging about a place they've been or a
person they've seen
you know
how do you feel about that
uh I don't mind it because all of us
kind of just do it we're taught to do
that sort of thing
um but I don't know if I'd necessarily
make those people my friends how does
how does it feel to be on the receiving
end of it every day
I understand it did you always
um
yeah actually I did did you ever
struggle with it um of course I
struggled with it for sure I'm asking
this for myself yeah yeah because well I
think look man we're always searching
for
um
a much deeper emotional connection to
another human being
you know it would I would much rather
have someone be like like this podcast
is a great example tell me about what it
was like growing up in your position and
if anyone ever asked me that I would be
an open book yeah you truly could come
up to me and ask me any question on the
street and I would probably hold a
tattoo with you
um but people want to show others yeah
but I don't
um don't do that uh
but I think people want to want to show
what they're up to right now and that's
totally fine and natural
um well I don't know if it's natural but
uh we're you know we're conditioned to
do that
but I think you know
whether it's you know you're doing it
ironically or authentically or
you're truly excited or you admire
someone or
you want to just prove to other people
I think most people have to understand
that there is probably a greater
connection to be made
that exists there's a choice that you
make when when you're asking for a very
surface level shallow interaction with
someone
um and that the alternative did exist
where you could probably deepen your
relationship to to
um an individual that you've wanted to
talk to
uh
so I don't really mind when people do it
it just means that person's not going to
be a cool connection to me personally
like I'm not gonna remember that
connection in my life when I'm telling
stories and things
whereas you know I did a movie called
five feet apart which um which dealt a
lot with cystic fibrosis and I've had a
lot of
um
people who live with cystic fibrosis
come up to me and talk to me about
cystic fibrosis and and talk to me about
that film and those are Connections in
my opinion that have lasted with me I
remember almost every single
conversation I've had with something
like that because it's not a uh yeah
let's take a pic it is hey man
um I want to let you know that I go
through this something that you were
trying to portray in this and and you
know this it affected me like this and
and it it's it's a discussion that
enriches both people
um and even if you don't like the
individual you know let's say you see
someone that you really don't like the
work of or you don't like the Persona of
going up and asking them a question is
probably going to yield so much more to
you than the alternative but we want to
show everything on Instagram and social
media and Tick Tock and whatever it is
because we want
you know we're all creatures of
validation we want to see the likes and
and the whatever the it is and I'm
I've done it too I'm not saying I
haven't done it you know I've I've taken
a picture or tried to take a picture of
John C Reilly who I really admire you
know I there's a lot of people that I I
deeply admire but if I were given the
choice between asking them a compelling
question and taking a photo I would
probably choose the compelling question
for sure that social anxiety if you will
really know what that's like people
without Fame will often experience
social anxiety for their own reasons as
well but when you say social anxiety can
you give me a picture of what that feels
like in reality oh sure uh pain and
image of it
you're very good at painting images with
your words by the way oh thank you
that's very you're enjoyable to listen
to you know what my social anxiety feels
a lot like
sitting in a sauna when it's just a bit
too hot like the sauna right before you
have to get out you know what I mean
it's it's like this warm sort of
blanketing feeling but it's not warm
it's hot it's but it's a blanket
over me for sure and it it it's this
kind of
for me anxiety is really present even
though I'm thinking about future
possibility or past
um
past actions that I've made it is a
consistent
um
I'm living in this I'm living in this
I'm living in this and so in that way
it's almost blanketed over me
um
and what I'll do for that anxiety is is
I will
activate my five senses
what do I see
what do I smell
what can I hear
Can I taste anything
what do I feel on my skin and it
immediately grounds me in the present
these things are grounding mechanisms
that I really enjoy when I start to feel
social anxiety have you learned that
somewhere
yeah I think I did where'd you where did
you learn that um well I did uh
I went to therapy I've had I've gone to
therapy off and on my whole life
um
but he was a wonderful man up in
Vancouver that taught me a sort of
grounding techniques
and he's right but I mean it does you
know it can be a therapist it can be a
father figure it can be anyone that
teaches you essentially the root of it
is be present grounded yeah it's it's
it's you know all the Eastern
philosophers and the Buddhists were
trying to tell you to do this the
whole time meditate ground yourself in
the present you know grounding yourself
in the present is the greatest enemy of
anxiety
what other tools have you learned from
therapy I feel like in a
I can learn a lot from you without
having to pay the therapist sure well
that's flattering
um
yeah I try not to talk too much about
mental health just in general
um
because everyone has an incredibly
personal relationship to it and I feel
like there's a lot of armchair experts
on the internet right now acting like
you know or diagnosing people or doing
stuff like that which I find Inc that is
so atrocious I can't believe people even
do that
um and I think the conversation about
around mental health unless it's being
done by truly a trained professional is
probably not the greatest thing to
listen to so with that disclaimer
I will say
um whenever I'm feeling heightened
emotionally I will take a break from
whatever I'm doing I will truly walk
away
from whatever I am doing I will tell if
it is an argument with someone I will go
hey
right now I'm feeling some heightened
emotion if you don't mind let's pick up
this conversation about 20 minutes
give yourself time
you know I I try to approach everything
with a kind of logos that that
you know
allows me to think more clearly and
calmly about what I do
um which can be off-putting to some
people
uh because not a lot of people like
being met uh
with logos when they're heightened
emotionally or being met with Solutions
when they're just trying to vent it's
one of the first things you learn when
you're in a serious relationship
especially as a guy
for sure because most a lot of a lot of
us are solution-based people you know um
but
I'll take a break that's the that's
honestly the most helpful thing I've
done I'll also try and remind myself of
you know grounding myself in the senses
or I will uh I'll remind myself that
one you're not the only person that's
ever gone through anxiety or will ever
go through anxiety and two
um the problem as you perceive it the
the vastness of the problem is you
perceive it is not the way other people
perceive it what about your relationship
with boundaries what please explain what
so you know you're the very first story
you told about being eight months old
eight months old you don't have
boundaries of course yeah so they are
obviously easily exploited as you grow
older sometimes when those boundaries
weren't firm when they were young and
you were maybe people pleasing or you
were seeking validation that can have a
sort of cascading effect into adulthood
what's your relationship been like with
saying no and protecting boundaries
whether it's professionally personally
in relationships well that's a great
question and one I'm far more qualified
to answer now than I was even two years
three years ago
um
I can honest to God say that I did not
love myself enough as a younger man
especially my mid to late 20s for sure
did not love myself enough did not
respect my own boundaries what did that
look like
um that looked like rolling over in the
face of a lot of adversity especially
when it came to romantic relationships
um I was a people pleaser I I was a
people pleaser professionally I was a
people pleaser uh romantically I was
practically a nurse to whoever
needed my help in very many ways likely
as a byproduct of my upbringing but
um what that meant was oftentimes
crossing my own boundaries as an attempt
to make others feel better
and as I've gotten older I've become
more okay with uh turning people off
which is all right
you know you're going to polarize
individuals you are going to get along
with certain people and not get along
with other people that's totally okay
and I think as I've aged
I've tried to um
I've tried to remind myself yeah that
was an awkward interaction that was a
bad interaction with someone but you're
gonna have those man that's okay
move on
and as I've Loved myself now and
thankfully I'm I you know I'm in a
relationship right now with a woman
who's so emotionally understanding and
and just the best and you know it helps
when others can be like yeah dude
encourage you in the right direction and
be like yeah it's okay like we're like
because I will I know myself I will fall
back on like are you all right like is
everything okay like like trying to
control a situation through making sure
everyone is happy you know but it's not
a you know it's not a video game
you can't get like the best solution
where everyone is okay sometimes you're
gonna really have to polarize some
people and that's all right my only
boundaries I would say uh when it comes
to
when it comes to my professional career
or otherwise
um I really don't like condescension
so like if I feel condescension in any
sort of way if I see other people being
condescending to others if if if I can
sense a kind of pretentiousness or
condescension that's usually something
that will either take me to leave the
room or confront another person about it
and be like hey why'd you why'd you do
that
what is um that relationship you
described what is love taught you about
yourself ah so much man
I've had
the pleasure of being in love three
times
the pleasure
um
I've had
I'd say three big relationships in my
life
three girlfriends in my life
um I mean my first one when I was like a
kid but that was just kind of puppy love
stuff and then I had one in college
um I dated a co-star on Riverdale
um and now I'm I'm in love again and
every time it has been pretty distinct I
think maybe the first two college and my
last girlfriend were far more similar
because of me
uh because I was still approaching it
the same way
um and then I did a lot of self work and
I fell in love again
um thankfully and it has taught me a lot
like I mentioned I was a people pleaser
I was deathly afraid of being perceived
as anything other than perfect for a
long time
and so I would roll over quite a bit in
order to make sure that
as long as they were happy that's what
love is you know as a sort of consistent
happiness
um and I was also actively suppressing
my emotions and like not really
discussing what I actually felt about a
situation because I was afraid of
retaliation in very many ways
um I was afraid where did that come from
oh I mean certainly my youth certainly
my youth your youth I think growing up
in you know building an entire life and
business model off of the validation of
other people certainly made me
um open to it but I also think the first
relationship I ever had with with a
female figure which is the mother figure
in everyone's life was an incredibly
tenuous and fractured relationship with
with um
with a a tortured individual which made
me go I can fix things don't worry I got
it you know no you're all good it's okay
um and I brought that in I brought that
in a lot were you trying to make her
happy
oh of course yeah I think so when I was
younger especially but even though I
wasn't an adult you know I didn't even
know yeah yeah of course you don't speak
your pretty mother anymore I don't I
don't but
um
she put me on this path and there was
once a woman who was very clear-headed
and
who had a beautiful
vision of the kind of people my brother
and I could be and in very many ways I
honor
the dream she once had so that if she
were Lucid enough
um
and came back and saw what I had become
she would go man I was right and in that
way it would validate the entire life of
pain and Trauma that she has gone
through are you are you sad about where
your relationship is with her of course
everyone is everyone is sad about
something that could I mean unless
you're a sociopath
um
when something beautiful and and lovely
goes rotten it can be a very sad thing
um
and it does make me sad but
it's also life and that's the lesson
that I've had to learn from it is that
you know that sadness is okay it means
I'm human it means I loved something
outside of myself
in a way that was so beautiful and so
boundless that it that it makes me feel
one of the strongest and most Eternal of
human emotions which is sadness like
real sadness and that's okay do you do
you does part of you like hold out and
this is kind of speaking from my
experience as well sure does part of you
kind of hold out for
things to just get better or go
completely wrong get better
outcome go completely wrong
um
I mean I'm sure you've reconciled this
as well but there's a part of you that
goes oh what if this is my last
communication with an individual you
know
of course you have how would that make
me feel as a consequence thereof how
would it make you feel
if this was you've never got a speech
your mother again you know and going
back to the previous question
I tried for very very many years to try
and to try and do everything I could
um
but at some point or another it comes
down to the individual which is the
hardest part
like you want someone to change or do
something and this also goes to romance
this goes to friendships this goes to to
blood to whatever it is you can really
yearn for someone to do the right thing
and the hardest part is even if you set
up the entire environment for them to do
so
uh unless they choose it for themselves
it's just not gonna happen and so I used
to blame myself quite a bit for not just
my relationship to blood but you know I
used to blame myself for all of the
relationships in my life going wrong
until I realized that yeah in almost
every relationship it takes two to tango
friendships romance blood some the other
person has to be a participant in the
dance just as much as you are
participating in the dance in order for
the outcome to be the one that you guys
both desire when you say that you used
to blame yourself for relationships in
your life going wrong yeah does that
mean that you originally blamed yourself
for the relationship with either your
mother or father or the relationship
between you and your mother going wrong
um I did because unfortunately as a
consequence of being a working child
you're forced into an authority position
when you're quite small right which is
now you're the breadwinner of a family
over the adults so in very many ways you
take this very strange like uh role of
authority and and positioning when it
comes to uh the subsistence of of a
nuclear family which is not a role a
child should be put in so when it does
go wrong as a natural byproduct of the
authority that you feel as a consequence
of you know your professional life you
can adopt some of the blame on yourself
which I will say I do not do anymore was
that are you talking about the divorce
there are you talking about relationship
with your mother yeah just everything
work mother whatever it is super
interesting yeah
yeah I mean dude it's this is also like
it should be said that
the working child a a child that has
worked since they were eight months old
you have to understand that that is a
not to sound like a special
snowflake as an identical twin you know
what I mean which is the greatest
contradiction but
that is a life
an upbringing that is very very very
very rare very rare not there's only a
handful of people that have that really
weird
um path through the world most of them
are in the United States and most of
them you know the sensationalism of
their of their upbringing is talked
about all over
um so that's um that comes with a lot of
and it affects to tie us all back I'm
getting us back good thank God for that
because I couldn't see how we'd make it
yeah
um that affects how you navigate
everything in your life your
relationships which is what we were
talking about friendships blood all that
stuff and my relationships were deeply
affected by my upbringing of course my
friendships were affected by my
upbringing my relationship to my family
was affected by my upbringing but at
some point or another you have to go
yeah I'm on the right path and even if
it's not I'll try and make it the right
path and I'll grow from them what makes
you alive then like what brings what
brings your heart to life these days
passionate conversation really for sure
without a doubt how many of them have
you had lots publicly
not publicly No in fact I've only done
one other podcast
um and these kind of public
conversations are quite rare which is
why I love this medium so much but I but
I've I've thankfully I've surrounded
myself with individuals that are capable
of all having these conversations and
for really diving into to what it is
that makes us all feel alive
um and I think
truthfully I think I think Seekers of
this kind of conversation find each
other it's weird they really do and you
can see it in others eyes like you can
see people that love this in their
eyes and so I thankful I I mean I host
dinner parties and stuff and try and get
as many people together to have these
sort of conversations and it can be a
little bit awkward for the first one
what are we talking about
um but that's incredibly enriching to me
okay so you've just you've just he teed
this up so perfectly perfect hit it
everything you've just described
the type of person that likes deep
conversations is very much the type of
people that listen to The Diary of a CEO
and we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where guests write a question in
the diary for the next guest they never
get to see who they're writing it for so
because we know that the type of person
that listens to this is by by clear
um linkage terrible use of words the
type of person that likes deep
conversations we wanted to take all of
the questions out of this diary that
have been written into them and allow
people to play at dinner parties the day
of SEO which is they can ask their
friends
deep conversations that have been
written into this book you also get to
see who wrote the the question for the
first time I want to play with you yeah
please right now ask me some questions I
am I took some cards out there's about
100 cards in total but I took the ones
that I thought were the biggest stitches
oh man that's a great idea I love that
so what I'm gonna do I will also answer
one yeah but I'm gonna lay them out here
you pick one that you want to answer
whichever one feels right for you then
I'll pick one as well and I'll answer it
we'll go through the all of them so
we'll pick one at a time
one
can I pick one so so you answer that one
I answer this one yeah this is by Tim
Grover this is what is your dark side
um
I think the Dark Side of myself is
definitely
the narcissistic side of myself that can
come out when I am feeling super proud
of something that I do and I will
oftentimes try to Humble that it'll get
me seeking decadence it'll get me
seeking external stimulation from my
environment and yearning for that which
is you know what every stoic philosopher
would be like dude shut up
um and I I really relate to that I think
my worst side is the side that is
seeking validation from other people
um rather than understanding and placing
myself in my environment and going wow
I'm so privileged to have what I have
and where I'm at and I believe that yeah
okay mine is from wilster who is an
expert on the topic of status who wrote
a book about it and which is kind of
about validation wanting to be famous
for sure who is the person you'd most
like to say sorry to but haven't
I told you I picked these questions to
stitch you up but I decided to answer
them when I laid them out so my would
actually be my mother yeah because she
didn't get an education so
um I've often framed her in my story as
being
I don't know like she she's been the
center point of difficult moments in my
life but she is also like the 95 of my
story with her is just this woman that
absolutely turquoise absolutely loves me
and my whole life her whole life is me
and and you know like growing up she did
everything for us she she raised us five
days a week she can't read or write
herself growing up she raised these four
kids that I think are all pretty good
decent kids
um so I'd say that I'd probably say
sorry to her for not spending enough
time in conversation talking about her
Brilliance and the fact that I am the
reason she's the reason I'm an
entrepreneur great answer man great
answer
I don't know I don't know
Rochelle Humes cool
if you could turn back the clock on one
day this year and do it differently what
day would it be and why
that's difficult
I try not to live doing that too much
where I feel like I need to change
something
but
um
so I am sober
I've been sober for about a year and
some change and it's been a wonderful
thing in my life
um
but I have
thankfully had the self-awareness to
apologize to some people in my life in
the past in a similar way that the card
that you just pulled
um
and in order to protect another person's
feelings I did not tell them that I was
going to be apologizing to an individual
um because I was afraid of the
consequences of that face-to-face
meeting I know this is a little
confusing but if I could turn back and
do it differently I would be so
transparent about that meeting over
coffee to the affected individuals in
order to be like hey I'm letting you
know this is happening I know that this
is blah blah blah but I just want to let
you know
with full transparency this is what it
is blah blah blah
um
but otherwise I try not to live like
that it's unclear you apologize to
someone and there was there was a
repercussion of that apology which you
wish you'd kind of foresaw and addressed
yeah okay exactly right cool exactly
right because sometimes meeting with
other people makes others uncomfortable
like they're you know especially
especially as you grow older some people
are like why'd you meet with that
individual but I think for me I would
have just been super
super transparent about it I'd be like
hey this is happening blah blah
um and that's been a consequence of the
work I've done as I've cleaned my life
up so I look back on that one day and I
go
hey man the work you did should have
told you that you could have been fully
transparent with that even if it made
other people uncomfortable and I
probably would have done that different
but otherwise
I try not I really try not to think like
that because they're lessons right
because it's all lessons because I made
that mistake for a reason you know and
now I'll never do it again and the fact
that I even said that as an answer means
I've already learned my lesson you'd
rather the lesson was in the past yeah
of course of course and in the future at
some point it's a place okay here we go
tell me something about yourself that
nobody knows and would be surprised to
know about you you know let's uh
hear about your internet history bro
Marissa Pierre um
so I had a guest on this podcast called
called Steve Peters who's just this
incredible like psychiatric psychiatric
therapist etc etc
um
after he left I contacted him and spoke
to him about something I was dealing
with this predicament in my mind and I
was bouncing between two outcomes and
it's the first time in my entire life
and I've spoken to so many therapists
that I've ever spoken to a therapist
privately to try and resolve something
and I say that because I say that for
one honestly just for one reason which
is I've spent so long on this podcast
talking to therapists including Marissa
pear who wrote this question and
Marissa's Marissa Pierre but I've never
spoken about the fact that I too have
spoken to a therapist about personal
challenges that I've faced and Marissa
Pierre is just one of the best ever and
so is um Professor Steve Peters do you
feel embarrassed I think I did I think I
did I think I think I always have I
think it's funny because
this is therapy for me and I lay it all
out you know I yeah the diversity was
Diary of a CO started as like my therapy
it was like me writing things in this
diary then sharing with them with the
world but I despite my guests
telling me about the profundity of
speaking to someone else as you have
today
as you did in Canada I believe I've
never done it myself until that moment
where I spoke to Steven said this is
what I'm dealing with like how do I
navigate through this and it's
incredible
I I think it'll
because you can't your brain can't think
yourself out of the no I I also
think a good therapist is like you know
your first house like like it arrives to
you precisely when it's supposed to you
know it because ultimately what we're
all seeking at least in therapy with the
help of a trained professional but it's
a human connection just to another
person you know we all want our Goodwill
Hunting you know we want to we want to
sit down and have someone who has a
a deeply enticing personal connection to
you and goes I hear you man I hear you
you're okay like have you thought about
it this way and so I do find a lot of
these kind of conversations can be
inching close to that and in that way
I'll say I do think there are a ton of
different forms of therapy you know of
self-soothing of methods I find a
tremendous therapy by going into the
Wilderness as an example you know I I
find that a really healthy thing for me
to do to sort of Disconnect and leave
and go into the woods and do all that
sort of stuff but I also think the other
stuff is super valuable too and I I
don't think there's any shame in talking
about it I think that's great I've
thought about it so many times in my
life like there's been so many moments
in my life I think like 10 where I've
seriously considered like I need I need
to go speak to someone else about this
because I can't figure this out myself I
remember like maybe two three years ago
I was there was some like business
um challenge I was facing and it was
just like keeping me up all night and I
remember going on the internet
contacting someone and being like can I
speak to you about this and it's because
I'm looking for a trained professional
like that can coach me through my
thought processes and what you've
described is so interesting to me
because you said two things the first
thing you said is therapy in essence is
like a pursuit of connection with
someone and then the second thing you
said is about how nature is therapy
these are all things that humans knew
very well in our Natural Life ten
thousand years ago man look I studied
archeology
and franchise over time because I know
that isn't that funny that therapy
is just being more human oh I I also
think look
we just wanna
we want to be heard man we we look for
soul
we all look for soul in other people we
want to know that Soul exists we want to
justify our soul by looking for soul in
other people and when you find people
with soul you want to hang on to people
with soul that's what we do
you know and I I think when you're
bearing your soul especially in a sort
of therapy environment you want someone
to to pick it up and go God I see this
thing man yeah I see it I did something
like this
so I mean for me it took me a while
finding a therapist that was um
that was willing to be Hands-On you know
there's this sort of uh hands-off
approach to a lot of
um you know
mental health work just in general and I
I just I can't do that man I need
someone like you know in a sort of
similar way to this there's two people
sitting down going God man yeah for sure
if therapy is is there for connection
then the thing that drives us to therapy
must be disconnection a feeling of
Distinction of course
when that disconnection can be anything
disconnection from nature from people
from life from purpose whatever yeah
it's it's
you know you become afraid of
your own soul being too disconnected
from from everything around you or that
or that you're that you feel so entirely
alone or unique that that
no one else really understands you is a
hard thing so so when you go into
therapy as an example and someone goes
yeah dude I hear you you know but then
if the if the alarm rings and
they go your hours up okay that to me uh
that's this connection that's just
connection because then it feels like a
monetary exchange I'm like I don't want
that all right
okay I'll take this haven't I done two
oh yeah that's the other one okay
how could you be more authentically You
by Fern cotton
is that pronounced correct yeah nailed
it perfect how could I be more
authentically you I mean I think stuff
more like this I gotta be less afraid of
of people going wow
he said what
I just don't care anymore I'm like I'm
dude I'm 30. I like I lived a lot of
that anxiety in in my 20s and I
truly believe that your 20s are meant
to be a petri dish for mistake that
you're supposed to learn lessons from
and go into your 30s and be be better at
and I and I don't know I think I am
practicing authenticity in a way but I
think it's complicated because I don't
know
if a life in the in entertainment people
actually seek authenticity which is
something I'm dealing with and I think
for acting it's also a real dilemma
because the more you show an authentic
version of yourself the harder it can be
for people to suspend that and see you
as a character
um which is something I'm sort of
sitting down and having a conversation
with myself about
um
but I'm not going to control what other
people think you know and I think uh
I think I am practicing authenticity in
very many ways how could I be more
authentically me
um stand on my ground set my boundaries
you know
recognizing my own bottom line behaviors
before I you know
stumble into that um
have you ever felt the cost of
authenticity of inauthenticity of
inauthenticity yeah yeah what is the
cost in your view
exposure
if you're exposed to be a fraudster yeah
if you're exposed to be a sort of snake
oil salesman that can be quite
embarrassing
um in inauthenticity can also get you
into a place where you actually don't
have the skill set to perform whatever
you're trying to perform but I also
think inauthenticity or feelings of
inauthenticity are a natural part of of
Courage you're going to doubt yourself a
little bit before you go into anything
and I I don't know I always find
my most effective uh means of surviving
anything is just kind of being thrown
into the fire and being like all right
I'm here what are we doing let's go
all right here we go no stitch
up
James Watt what is the belief that you
hold that most people disagree with you
on so many in fact yeah that's great man
that's good
um the first one I'm gonna say is what's
the thing that most people disagree with
me on trying to decide between I'm gonna
say I'm gonna say the point about
manifestation
um I think this is super controversial
because anything that
gives centers people on a sense of
personal responsibility is typically not
well received like people don't love the
concept of personal responsibility
obviously there's lots of nuance to this
but I would say that when the way that
society and culture and Instagram have
described the process of manifestation
is largely
um and I think that manifest like
knowing that like the example always
give is getting in the current sector
Sat Nav is of course important because
if I just drove without Direction I'd be
lost but if I don't drive
I'm also just sat in my garage with a
Sat Nav set all day
um
I don't think you can just manifest your
your yourself your way there in life I
think luck plays a huge role
circumstance plays a huge role where you
live if I was still in Botswana there's
not going to be a dire of a CEO
interviewing you today right sure maybe
if my if if my mum hadn't met my dad so
there's circumstance there's luck there
is will there is hard work there is
trauma there's conviction and then there
is also a an importance to know the
direction you're going in but I think
manifestation as an idea is oversold
because it makes life easy and
comfortable and it also it obfuscates us
of the responsibility of work and
personal responsibility I think it is I
think it's
absurd to pursue comfort
absurd and anything you do
I think at some point or another when
your hands are on the wheel in this car
with the sat nav you're gonna have to
drive and if the sat nav goes
out
um
okay man you're still behind the wheel
driving a vehicle you know I I
think
you also have to really strongly believe
in yourself really strongly believe in
yourself because there's a lot of things
that people love gatekeeping it's
crazy everyone loves it especially on
the internet they love gatekeeping it's
like the first thing you're going to
interact with when you jump into
something new people are gonna go not
that guy
you know what weren't you doing this or
uh don't do don't talk about that don't
do this people love gatekeeping which is
so funny because it the the idea that we
have to be like these incredibly
specialized needle fine like kind of
people is ridiculous you know I I
try everything go into it boldly but you
gotta believe in your success and you
have to take accountability have you
struggled with that late that idea of
being labeled as something because well
of course you know there's people
listening to this now who are like a
lawyer or they are sure or whatever
right and they want they have this
passion for something else it could be
photography like you but they're a
lawyer they're bio says lawyer their
LinkedIn says lawyer and the resistance
the social resistance but also the
psychological resistance of
now that label is creating keeps them
confined in a way that is not fulfilling
or conducive with a happier life so
breaking out of those labels when you're
a you know a star from such a young age
you get your label super early yeah Cole
you are an actor and there are many ways
a child star is what I'm called quite
often yeah which
okay but dude I mean look anyone that
doesn't think outside of terms of labels
it's just useless to me I I gotta be
real like anyone that cannot find
a deeper Humanity in whatever
um whatever kind of person they're
sitting across at a table is probably a
pretty useless person to talk to in my
opinion um I think labels can be
difficult and and also helpful in very
many ways let's say you're a lawyer yeah
man make that money on that on that
label sure make that money on that label
and then surround yourself with the
people that don't see you as this is my
lawyer friend you know
because you don't need that many people
you need a round table of people that
are going to be like yeah that's coal
cool wow what a Renaissance human that
guy is you know that's what you really
want people to say oh man what a good
person that person is you know that's
great
the label thing can be difficult but
I think it's useless to think like that
I I think anyone that goes wow you know
this
anything outside of human you know is
silly and I know this sounds a bit
woo-woo and pretentious and because it
does be like don't label me ah
but um I think it's true I I I I don't
think thinking in terms of labeling is
useful in the slightest in the slightest
and I I would like to think at the end
of all of our Lives we we've we've
surrounded ourselves with you know a
rich enough body of experience to go
yeah man I tried blacksmithing for a
period of time yeah dude I crafted a
little necklace well I was a silversmith
for about a year and I tried that
out and it went really well
um and I think people are going to try
and gatekeep you but I I think what I
mean is that you're always gonna have to
fight against some sort of label
regardless of what it is and if there's
a bouncer at the door gate keeping you
from getting inside the club guarantee
you that there's a side entrance
guarantee you and you got you gotta
fight your way to get there man I I I'm
a firm believer in that and you have
told us to recognize the kind of
um restrictions that are being put on
you but I think you always got to fight
for yourself if you don't fight for
yourself legitimately no one else is
going to
earlier on you said something to me you
said have I ever you said have I ever
sort of hypothetically played out the
scenario that that person in my life my
mother might not be here and sure
reflecting upon that being the last
conversation I'd had with her how would
I feel I've got two pictures here
what are the words unsaid to this
individual
that's my father
and that could be my brother or myself I
have no idea what are the words that are
not said to that individual
um
you were at the exact place that you
were supposed to be right when you were
supposed to be there
for sure
my father
was 27. when he had two identical twin
boys
that's big
you know I'm 30. I can't imagine having
two identical twins I'm sorry to expose
you property immediately got a vasectomy
right after he found out he was having
two twins I just find that hilarious
it's my favorite story about him
um
he was an Italy at the time I'd say man
what is your hair routine it's looking
great
uh he looks like a study this is a sad
photo yeah yeah for sure good job pop
um you're at the exact place you need to
be right when you were supposed to be
there and whatever happens in the
following years are all
the lessons
that you need to take
for the future of your life
but every step of the way you've been
exactly where you're supposed to be for
sure
the words uncertain to this person
it's funny I was thinking about writing
that in this journal what would you say
to your child itself that's funny
this kid
um
this is me on the left
Dylan on the right
um
I wouldn't want to condition this kid at
all
I see a kid that's like so present in
this moment and I've had this dilemma
because I have some step siblings and I
find myself wanting to ask them like hey
you've been thinking about college
hey like what are you thinking about in
the future
um
I think I'd probably just talk to this
kid about like hippos or platypus or
some some fun you know
Pokemon whatever it was
I don't I don't think it's
wise to
put the future or past tense thinking of
an adult onto a child and I think it's
your responsibility as an adult who
loves a child to encourage that Lantern
Consciousness and that presentedness for
as long as you can
and as far as you can and anything that
takes them away from that presentedness
should be the enemy
of
your life in that child's life isn't
that what happened to you yeah it is
it is and that was the perfect lesson I
needed to know for my eventual children
what about Dylan
my brother and I have made it this far
and have been as okay as we have become
because we did not feel
lonely
we always had each other as a frame of
reference to grow up and alongside and I
think um I think I'm incredibly
privileged for that and he is too
we thankfully got to go through
everything we went through alongside
each other
and I think that's built him into the
exact kind of person he's supposed to be
and me as well
and I really am living my life now in a
place where I don't look back with
regrets or anger or or pain or anything
like that so
um I don't know I'd probably kick his
ass honestly if I'm thinking about it
now
I probably I'd probably smile at myself
and then beat the hell out of Dylan
and I'd have reach advantage and stuff
too it'd be great
I'm just throwing by his legs like
Bowser
we have a closing tradition this podcast
with the last guest asks a question for
the next guest the question that's been
left for you
you have one last piece of work to do
what is that piece of work and why
if I had children
make sure that
they were okay
try and make sure Ensure
that whatever I could do is My Last
Action would create
more easiness for them
um
because life is Gonna Roll Over you
regardless you know regardless of how
easy you've had it I would try to have
one last thing said or done that helped
them in the future you went straight to
Children yeah and if I was a grandfather
I would take all of my cash
and convert it into some sort of gold
Doubloon
and I would bury that
I'm not telling you where
but I would send them on the greatest
treasure hunt ever I mean really give
them one one thing that they said God
Grandpa wasn't saying
but what a story he gave us you know
Goonies Style
I want I want to be
I want to be the guy that like sends his
grandkids I'm like oh grandpa Cole was
just insane man but man he was a wacky
guy he found the treasure I wouldn't
make it too hard you know but I'd want
them to go someplace sounds like a great
movies plot yeah maybe maybe they'll
write it who knows grandfather Cole work
is interesting though it's a really
interesting question because I hope I'm
not working really
I don't like I hope I don't see it as
work okay you didn't see photography is
work no no I don't see acting like the
stuff I feel really passionate about as
as uh as work either have you ever had a
conversation like this one publicly
no
I think it'll be fun
cool thank you yeah a huge honor yeah
and tremendously valuable for for me
more than I could probably tell you but
meeting people like you that have gone
through unique life experiences and are
able to look back introspectively and
sort of
um historically and depict that in such
a self-aware honest vulnerable way is
the very reason I started doing this and
the very reason I continue to do it um
so I thank you because it's a real I
feel like you've um
I feel like I feel like I owe you
something for being I know this is how I
always feel for for all of the lessons I
know for the rest of my life get to go
on with from your journey and um as a
fan of yours now both your art and your
photography I guess are the same thing
you're but but just for semantics
um I'm gonna follow I'm gonna continue
to follow you with a renewed perspective
on on your humility your talent and your
Humanity well thank you and by the way
um every conversation like this we trade
just as much for anyone that's
empathetic which you seem to be
um
you trade just as much this is a beauty
you and I were both August 1992 from
very different backgrounds and yet we
can still sit around a round table
and go man I know the feelings of what
you've gone through even though you and
I are very different people yeah and I
think that's the beauty of it you know
that's the beauty of of
that connection I've been talking about
I think
empathy is the currency of all this
stuff and you've asked some really
wonderful questions and I'm glad that I
was able to answer in a way that that
hopefully brought out something but uh
thank you again thank you for having me
that was really wonderful thank you
[Music]
it's now been a healed Drinker for about
four years roughly so much so that I
ended up investing in the company
um and I play a role on the board of the
company but they also very kindly
sponsor this podcast and to be honest
I've never said this before but he will
believed in this podcast before anybody
else the CEO Julian
um told me before we even launched the
podcast how successful it would be and
that he'll would back it and I
absolutely have a huge amount of
gratitude for them for that support but
an even greater sense of gratitude for
the fact that they've helped me stay
nutritionally complete throughout the
chaos and hecticness of my tremendously
busy business schedule so if you haven't
tried out here which I hope most of you
have at least given it a go by now try
it out it's an unbelievable way to try
and stay nutritionally on course if you
have a hectic busy schedule and let me
know what you think send me a tweet and
a DM tag me let me know what you think
quick quote from one of our sponsors I
have to say I've been on a bit of a
journey with this brand because when I
started my business in new territories
when we first moved social chain to the
to New York City the first place we went
to was wework we moved four of our team
members out to New York City and we
built the business from there
um I have to say there's something
magical about weworks I've spent the
last two or three weeks in LA in a wee
work and as you walk in the front door
every day it's almost like that sense of
community that sense of magic excitement
camaraderie is tangible and you don't
get that when you're working at home you
don't get that often when you're sat in
your bed on your laptop there's
something about getting out and getting
into a wee work that makes me feel a
sense of Entrepreneurship and and
creativity and building and the way that
we work to design both both in the way
that they offer subscriptions so that
you can work you know on demand but also
the the flexibility of the contracts
means that it's just the perfect place
for businesses to scale their companies
and if you haven't checked out where you
work and you want to you can go to
we.co CEO and there you can get 50 off
at trial Day At wework Close to You
[Music]
thank you